I know wasn't it hard to like traveling
and I was like please don't get wrinkled
oh my God I know you're just like like
stiff light as a feather seven is a
blood okay so you're presenting tonight
yeah it's not going to what you're gonna
wear like are you thinking about like
walking across that stage or you're like
no I want a moment what I should have
I didn't I should have well you've been
walking on the carpet so I think you'll
survive it's okay yeah yeah so Bumper in
Berlin was renewed for a second season
yes it has what's your reaction to that
oh I was so excited to be able to work
with everybody again I mean Megan amram
are showrunner is just a genius an utter
genius I love working with her she's an
amazing human being and to be back again
with Adam and flu lunch and Mila and
Lira it's just um we have an amazing
cast and amazing directors and Crews so
uh it's it's a lot of fun and like I'm
like what songs are we gonna sing this
year do I have can I pitch anything like
you should I think you should I don't
know I I feel like you know the Pitch
Perfect fans are no joke and so they
really have gone hard for you guys and
like there's some shows you don't even
know if they're gonna last one season so
I'm happy for you though thank you so
much and real quick Wells and you have
you guys been listening to Chris
Harrison podcast at all is that
something that you guys were like
excited to see I I haven't listened to
it yet I think he texted Wells about it
being like heads up I talked about you
in the second episode but I don't know
what he said or anything it was positive
stuff just said by having the support of
everybody loves Wells exactly I mean
it's Wells
and here he makes a mean Margarita so
I'm gonna have to die he does
[Music]